there is a strong link between being
gender non-conforming and growing up gay
it's by no means 100 there are plenty of
a link or correlation a strong
correlation very strong like 20 or 25
times more likely to grow up gay if
you're highly highly gender and
conforming to the extent that the people
around you would notice yes compared to
the general population that said there
are still plenty of sweet little boys
who love ballet who grow up to be
straight and you know girls who can't
stand Thrills and want to be climbing
trees and love football and so on but
just numbers wise there's a strong
correlation so most of the kids who saw
the early gender doctors there were very
few of those kids but most of them were
same-sex attracted when they passed
puberty and the first studies which
tracked the kids but didn't do any
interventions and that almost all those
kids stopped saying I want to be a boy
or I want to be a girl or I think I
really am a girl
they just accepted themselves as gay
puberty taught them who they were